monsieur le ministre Mesdames et
Messieurs les dames les rapporteurs
l'examen d'une motion référendaire une
première dans cette enceinte depuis une
décennie est un moment d'une extrême
gravité démocratique nous parlementaire
n'avons pas vocation à nous dessaisir de
la mission que nous ont confié les
citoyens et les citoyens de délibérer et
voter la loi
et si nous sommes favorables à davantage
d'implication citoyennes dans la
fabrique de la loi la binarité du
référendum semble souvent peu
compatibles avec l'exercice complexe de
rédaction et de vote de la loi
alors pourquoi cette motion
tout d'abord parce que ce débat
parlementaire est une farce
le gouvernement a choisi un véhicule
législatif inadapté jamais utilisé pour
une réforme de cette ampleur qui corset
le débat dans le temps et dans l'espace
en interdisant de l'élargir au-delà des
paramètres financiers symboles s'il en
est que pour vous le nettoyage n'est
qu'un coup
au moins en son temps Édouard Philippe
avait eu le courage de proposer un vrai
projet de loi et une vision nous la
contestions évidemment mais elle avait
le mérite de proposer autre chose autre
chose qu'une réforme de comptable en
costume gris destiné à faire payer au
travailleur les cadeaux fiscaux offerts
aux entreprises et au plus aisées le
Sénat doit donc examiner et c'est une
délétère première historique un texte
qui n'a pas été voté par l'Assemblée
nationale qui doit absolument être voté
avant le 12 mars minuit faute de quoi le
carrosse redeviendra citrouille mais et
nous sommes ici en Absurdie la
citrouille peut tout de même faire
l'objet d'un examen en commission mixte
paritaire ou d'une adoption par
ordonnance la Cinquième République n'est
jamais en reste pour piétiner le
Parlement mais la présidence Macron a
innové comme aucun autre avant-elle dans
la dérive autocratique d'un exécutif
hors-sol isolé dans sa tour d'ivoire
isolé ou devrais-je dire plutôt dire non
content de mépriser le parement de
mépriser les partenaires sociaux de
l'éveil contre vous un front social qui
comme rarement sait qui comme rarement
c'est le peuple de France tout entier
que vous méprisez depuis des mois tous
les sondages affichent une opposition
ferme et constante aussi ont entre deux
tiers et les trois quarts de nos
concitoyens plus vous méprisez leur
intelligence et invoquer le besoin de
faire de la pédagogie de votre réforme
plus les Français s'y opposent les
manifestations enregistrent semaine
après semaine des records de
participation et les préavis de grève
tombent les uns après les autres pour
faire du 7 mars et de la prochaine
semaine un moment historique de
l'histoire du mouvement social alors que
nous sortons à peine de la pandémie
alors que la guerre gronde offronter
iente à l'Europe alors que l'inflation
explose alors que la climatique nous
heurte plus fort que jamais au point de
nous obliger à rationner l'eau source de
toute vie vous n'avez aucun scrupule à
conduire le pays tout entier au blocage
mais pour quel besoin pour quelle
urgence est-ce la nécessité d'un agenda
caché de vos négociations avec la
Commission européenne ou est-ce la seule
fierté mal placée du président de la
République qui considère que le barrage
à l'extrême droite vaut à doublement de
sa Royal personne et qui n'a même pas
pris la peine d'étudier la composition
de la potion qui n'entend faire boire au
pays et à laquelle il n'a visiblement
pas compris grand chose le retrait de
ces textes s'impose cependant pour vous
éviter de perdre la face nous vous
proposons une solution alternative
soumettent donc ce projet dont vous êtes
si fier à l'approbation des Françaises
et des Français ils sont 70% à le
demander 70% à vouloir se prononcer sur
cette réforme 70% à vouloir être maître
de leur propre destin 70% à vouloir
expérimenter leur parfaite compréhension
de votre projet de ces prétendus mesure
de justice d'égalité femme homme et de
prise en compte de la pénibilité tout à
sa réélection dont il ne cesse de se
prévaloir abusivement Emmanuel Macron
alors interrogé sur la possibilité
d'avoir recours référendum sur la
réforme des retraites déclaré le 11
avril je n'exclus pas le référendum pour
quelques formes que ce soit je les dis
je suis pour le retrouver notre
discussion ne permet de clarifier les
choses l'occasion est ici toute trouvée
ce même Emmanuel Macron qui en appelait
au bon sens des Français à l'occasion de
leur faire réellement confiance
mes chers collègues notre démocratie est
malade il est inconcevable de trouver
dans nos deux chambres une nette
majorité pour un prorer j'ai rejeté par
la grande majorité de nos concitoyennes
et de nos concitoyens notre
représentativité est dramatique et notre
légitimité légitimité et menacée il
convient une fois n'est pas coutume de
nous dessaisir de cette réforme de ne
pas voter brutalement dans un déni de
démocratie manifeste cette réforme
bricolée dont personne ne veut nous
avons besoin comme le disait de Gaulle
de savoir ce qu'il en est dans les
esprits et dans les cœurs mes chers
collègues de droite soyez Gaulistes
n'ayez pas peur du peuple votez cette
motion référendaire
[Musique]